as a medic and evolved you have a solemn
responsibility a sworn duty a prime
directive that overrides all other
concerns keep your team of hunters alive
pretty much everything on Scheer wants
to kill them and you but you are the
only one who can heal the crew and keep
them in fighting form but Chris what
about this sick sniper rifle I got man
eye mask or monster head shots all day
no I don't even want you equipping that
rifle until healing becomes your first
your last your everything follow the
following tips and they'll be naming
oaths after you in no time
let's start with Val whenever val is in
the match the real contest becomes the
battle of the health bars between her
and the monster Val's med gun heals
versus the damage the monster deals by
keeping those healed juices flowing you
can prolong the time it takes the
monster to incapacitate your allies and
minimize the amount of end cap strikes
they receive each strike lowers their
maximum health and three strikes forces
the dropship respawn so let's just try
to avoid that shall we here's the thing
about the Med gun it has a really long
range like way longer than you think
probably so get yourself to high ground
where you can see your team scrapping it
out below and get to healing you should
almost always focus on whoever the
monster is attacking at that time unless
that person is shielded then maybe he'll
someone else who needs it real bad or if
that person is getting torn apart and
it's clearly doomed then maybe top off
your other teammates and start planning
your revive anyone can revive an in
capped player but Val can use her med
gun to do it from a distance she can
also use the heal burst to fuel a
dramatically faster revive but this
requires you to be near the injured
person which also means you're near the
monster which is no good better to use
your med gun to stay out of harm's way
as long as you can the monster will
eventually get real tired of your
medical antics and follow the bright
green line that leads it right to you
this is where mobility becomes paramount
take a jetpack recharge or a jump height
increased perk at the beginning of the
match to amplify your movement and save
your heal bursts for keeping yourself
alive during these encounters because
ain't nobody healing you except you
and when fleeing the monster try to
escape in the direction of your
teammates so that they can draw its
aggression it can also help to dose the
beast with a shot from your tranquilizer
gun cranking the monster doesn't just
put a neon outline around it for easy
visibility it also drastically cuts its
movement speed and severely impairs any
movement related abilities so Goliath
can't leap as far Kraken can barely fly
and the rates teleport is much less
teleport be not only contracting help
you get out of a dangerous situation but
it's also a great asset for tipping the
combat scales in your favor if you can
pepper in some armor-piercing sniper
rifle shots as well and you're really
cooking targets it leaves on the monster
lets your buddies do double damage so
try to put them on a chest or a head
instead of a tentacle or a tail so
they're easy to hit tranq and punch
holes and armor intermittently but
always remember that the single best
thing that you can ever do is heal I've
seen too many medics get caught up in
the glory and glamour of shooting the
actual monster those medics are dead
mechs and also dicks having your buddies
die as Val means that you didn't do your
job
having your buddies die as the second
medic Lazarus means it's time to go to
work the Lazarus device is a miraculous
test-tube wizard fist that quickly
revives in caps allies or resurrects
dead ones and it does so without causing
any end cap strengths note that this
doesn't replace Lazarus's ability to do
a normal non medical revival so be sure
you're actually whipping out your power
glove and firing it to gain the full
benefits unless you're dead buddies get
eaten or decompose you can always bring
them back from the dead this basically
negates the fact that the monster over
down them and has a monster there is
nothing more infuriating
which is why Lazarus is number one
priority is not to heal allies but to
avoid getting mauled by the monster
seriously a hero level Lazarus can swoop
in with a well-timed feel burst when all
his allies are hurtin but you are not
that Lazarus I mean something personal
like we totally
be one day but until you've got your
revival and evasion game down pat save
the he'll burst for yourself or for one
like randos take a bite out of someone
when you're just jogging around the back
stay out of the fray you creepy necro
medic and put that silent sniper rifle
to work the weak spots you create on the
monster aren't as powerful as Valles but
you can make a lot more a lot more
quickly snipe the monster watch your
teammates get bloody and when they start
dropping you start reviving it's kind of
morbid just to watch everyone you know
get thrashed but that's how Lazarus
rolls get on voice chat and tell your
teammates to leave the revives to you
they should draw the monster away from
downed allies so you can do your thing
and if they're gonna die can they at
least have the decency to spread
themselves out a little bit first
that'd be great the personal cloak is
great for invisible in your way to a
revived gig but while you're actually
patching their boo-boos or hauling their
soul back from the beyond
you'll be visible make sure that the
monster is distracted and that you have
an exit plan and remember jetpack usage
is still visible when the rest of you is
invisible and so is fire if you happen
to be on fire fire is generally not good
but don't tell that to Kyra the third
medic her fire grenades can cause the
monster some serious discomfort but like
Val before her Kyra is a healer and stay
healing grenades for healing these
projectiles are a skill shot meaning you
have to aim each one unlike Val's
lock-on med gun but they do create a
healing first so you can get a few
allies in one shot if they're close
together and you can heal yourself by
shooting the floor or the wall which
means you can be a bit less selfish with
your heal burst getting to an elevated
position and looking down on it all as
Kyra lets you rain healing and burning
an alternate measure but a Ken please oh
please focus on the healing you are the
medic not the pyro that's this guy
hi ground isn't just good for the views
it's also better for evasion because
leaping and falling through the air
allows you to cover more distance and
get tricky with your jetpack
manoeuvrability is one of Kairos strong
suits thanks to her acceleration field
flick it on at the beginning of a match
to catch up with the monster and force
an early encounter while it's still a
wee baby or activate it during a fight
to zip in and deliver a crucial healing
burst or if God forbid you're the last
one standing and things look bleak kick
it on to G the FO medica ain't easy but
few players are more impactful than a
good doc and the satisfaction you'll get
from thwarting the monster is the good
stuff
follow these tips share your own in the
comments and happy healing
you